Jennifer Aniston pays tribute to her
late Father John Aniston who died on
November 11th he was 89 years old you're
Jennifer Aniston's death I am Jennifer
Aniston's dad and I am so excited I just
can't hide it
on Monday Jen shared several pics with
her dad alongside a sweet caption which
read in part quote you were one of the
most beautiful humans I ever knew I am
so grateful that you went soaring into
the heavens in peace and without pain
and on 11 11 no less you always had
perfect timing the actress added that
she'll love her dad till the end of time
before concluding quote don't forget to
visit
this is truly
um a special moment for me it's an
opportunity to not only pay tribute to a
true icon in the daytime television
world but it's also a chance to
recognize the lifelong achievements of a
great and well-respected actor who also
happens to be my dad back in June Jen
honored her dad at the 2022 daytime
Emmys where he won the Lifetime
Achievement Award for over 30 years his
dedication to that show has gained him
the respect and admiration of his fellow
actors deep friendships and thrilled
millions of fans around the world his
career is literally the definition of
Lifetime Achievement John was best known
for his role as Victor kiriakis on the
soap opera Days of Our Lives
I cannot do this Maggie
that I can keep it from happening again
Jen's Mom Nancy Dow died in 2016 at 79
years old and the actress recently
opened up about her parents divorce in
Allure magazine quote I forgave my mom I
forgave my father I've forgiven my
family you have to be so proud I am yeah
oh yeah what is it like for you to sit
and watch Jennifer take off
it's very exciting yeah it's very
exciting you know I'm just it Thrills me
all that every time I see her in
addition to his role on Days of Our
Lives John also made guest appearances
on hit shows like The West Wing a
candidate will be asked a question by
one of the panelists and he will have 90
seconds to respond Gilmore Girls so you
didn't apply to just Harbor did you
Star Trek Voyager unlike other planets
in this system
we Grant Our Guest workers the full
protection of our laws and Mad Men He is
survived by Jen his wife Sherry Rooney
who he married in 1984 and their 33 year
old son Alex Aniston
foreign